So having one box that we've made, or one model building that we've made is
great, but I chose a certain size that I wanted these squares to be. So I'm
wondering what's going to happen if I choose a different sized square. Let's
see. Maybe to start out my experiment, I'll make a rectangle that has little
tiny, tiny, tiny squares cut out of the corners.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
So now that I have my tiny squares cut out, I'm going to cut out some really
big ones. Actually, I'm going to consider, first of all, this box as our
medium-sized corner box. And for comparison, I'm just going to take that tape
off of it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
. So medium one is back. Now for the really big one, or rather the really big
corners.
[BLANK_AUDIO].
So now, we have three very different looking rectangles with the corners cut
out of them. And the question I have for you and something that Athena's
wondering is which one of these has the biggest volume when it's folded into a
box? Or in other words, which one's going to hold the most M&amp;M's? Clearly we
want the box that's going to hold the most M &amp; M's. So pick between these three
boxes.